wir haben eben gerade diese drohung
diese fassung kriegsdrohungen von
lukaschenko gehört was muss die antwort
sein na ja das muss erst mal jemand da
sein der sie formuliert ich frage mich
ja wo ist eigentlich olaf scholz wo es
olaf der mann von dem wir über monate
gehört haben scholz kann kanzler
vertrauen in diesen mann dem viele leute
in deutschland viele wähler ihr
vertrauen gegeben haben mit ihrer stimme
millionen
spd-wähler millionen grünen-wähler die
auch auf ihn zählen als kanzler aber er
ist unsichtbar ist weg er schweigt zu
den wichtigsten thema dieser tage und
das finde ich nicht statthaft weil olaf
scholz wir erinnern uns kurz vizekanzler
ist als er ist geschäftsführend im amt
er ist übrigens der einzige der sich
nicht rausreden kann mit naja ich bin ja
jetzt dann nicht mehr dabei er wird ja
kanzler also wir haben einen vizekanzler
der kanzler wird und der jetzt
abgetaucht ist und ich glaube
dass ich sowas erkenne in seine methode
scholz die wären nämlich auch in hamburg
schon mal gesehen haben beim g-20-gipfel
und diese methode scholz lautet
abtauchen wenn es draußen brennt es in
der elbphilharmonie und hat sich
klassische musik angehört als
linksextreme hamburg abgefackelt haben
und jetzt sitzt er in irgendwelchen
ampel verhandlungen kommt raus steigt
und sein auto fährt weg beantwortet
fragen nicht nach der flüchtlingskrise
und ist wieder abgetaucht bild hat ihn
gestern ja angefragt und darauf hat er
erklärt heute nicht also ist er heute
nicht kanzler und wenn das sozusagen die
überschrift ist über das was uns jetzt
mit ihm als kanzler bevorsteht dann bin
ich doch besorgt oder anders gesagt ich
glaube er hat noch bevor kanzler ist
aber nochmals ja vizekanzler bevor er
kanzler ist die große chance mit einem
neuen werk in den duden aufgenommen zu
werden schulzen bedeutet abtauchen wenn
es draußen brennt der heute nicht
kanzler der oder künftige kanzler der
abt auch der weg scholz sozusagen wie du
sagst claus strunz das sind auch ihre
flüchtlinge herr scholz sagst du jetzt
haben wir eine besondere situation die
eine regierung die alte regierung kann
nicht mehr will nicht mehr richtig die
andere ist noch nicht ganz ist ja kein
zufall dass gerade jetzt in diesem
moment lukas schenk und putin ein
pieksen dass sie genau diesen moment
ausnutzen wie müssten wir jetzt die
stirn bieten diesen beiden naja erstmal
fällt ja auf dass wir wieder auf nichts
vorbereitet sind also wann ich auf die
pandemie vorbereitet wir waren nicht auf
die flut vorbereitet und jetzt sind wir
nicht auf etwas vorbereitet von dem jahr
wissenschaftler experten mehr noch
politiker wissen dass es jetzt nicht
sozusagen von heute auf morgen
entstanden ist sondern dass
migrationsbewegungen die große
herausforderung der jetztzeit sind und
jetzt finden sie statt und wir sind
wieder nicht vorbereitet und natürlich
kann man nicht gelten lassen dass wir
jetzt keine regierung haben wir haben
eine geschäftsführende kanzlerin wir
haben einen geschäftsführenden vize
kanzler der übrigens kanzler wird aber
wir handeln sehr zurückhaltend und
deshalb muss olaf scholz heute
eigentlich folgende fragen beantworten
und nicht wenn ich sie morgen oder
übermorgen oder am samstag oder nächste
woche oder in einem vierteljahr passt er
muss jetzt die frage beantworten wohin
mit den flüchtlingen herr scholz
schicken wir bundeswehr in polen die
bundeswehr an fordert herr scholz wie
ist ihre haltung zu der migrations
entwicklung und politik bevor sie
bundeskanzler werden wollen wir bürger
das von ihnen wissen und wir wollen auch
wissen wie sie mit einer grün gelb roten
regierung mit der berühmten ampel denn
künftig diese fragen beantworten wollen
ich glaube also ich konnte mir vorher
wahrscheinlich vorstellen wie das
migrations thema zwischen grün und fdp
irgendwie vermittelt werden
kann und das schöne irgendwie haben
jetzt auch alle glück als bürger denn
jetzt wird s nicht weggespült werden
können in koalitionsverträgen also so
nach dem motto wenn eine
flüchtlingsbewegung kommt oder wir sind
für den spurwechsel von asyl zur
einwanderung all diese dinge die er
gerne zu koalitionsverträgen stehen
sondern wir haben jetzt den reality
check können grüne und fdp zu dieser
frage eine gemeinsame regierungsposition
entwickeln unter der führung von olaf
scholz und ich habe da große zweifel als
anderson für das überhaupt generell
nicht nur heute sondern auch in den
vergangenen wochen im wahlkampf bei
irgend jemand dieses thema ganz groß auf
der agenda steht man hat das gefühl
derzeit streitet man ob man sie im klima
in klimafragen irgendwie einig wird ja
das ist ja auch für bequeme weil
sozusagen erstmal die katastrophe viel
weiter entfernt ist das ist also bequem
er sich da einzulassen und man sieht ja
dass die rhetorik der politik die beim
klima verwendet wird jetzt auch versucht
wird auf die flüchtlings entwicklung an
zur anwendung zu finden wir müssen
härtere sanktionen verhängen wir müssen
fluglinien irgendwie davon abhalten dass
sie fliegen also das liegt alles im
morgen und übermorgen und keinen
konkreten plan die flüchtlinge sind aber
an der grenze und schneiden den zaun auf
und jetzt wird überprüft ob unsere
regierung realitäts fit fit ist das ist
der stresstest für die ampel und sie
schweigt und die eine seite die steht
die hat eine klare meinung zur liga ist
stärker als andere seite ist dass eine
charakterfrage ich glaube es ist eine
systemfrage ich glaube dass ich eine
demokratie in einer auseinandersetzung
mit einem diktator immer schwer tut weil
zurecht hier recht und gesetz gelten
weil menschenrechte im vordergrund
stehen zu recht 5 ausrufezeichen um die
sich der andere nicht schert es ist also
so als würde den kampf und auf einem
königspudel treffen der königspudel wir
wissen es eine der intelligentesten
runde am schluss ist aber tot und das
ist sozusagen das problem deswegen der
politik sehen wenn ein diktator vom
schlage lukaschenkos mit einem halb
diktator vom schlage putins gemeinsame
sache machen und uns neuerdings keine
raketen schicken sondern flüchtlinge und
das sind jetzt auch ihre flüchtlinge
herrschers